My name is Joe DIY.
I restore old toy trucks,
and today I'm going to
be walking you through
the restoration of a 1960s
Structo airport lift truck.
These toys are considered
pressed-steel toys.
That means they take
a sheet metal aluminum
and they use a hydraulic press
to kind of form it into shape.
The truck's pretty rusty.
It's mostly complete, which is good,
'cause they're hard to find parts for.
The only thing that's really missing
was a lot of the lights and mirrors
that you'll see on the roof.
Whenever I take things apart,
I always start at the wheels,
and then I'll move on
and start taking the body off the chassis
and kind of work my way
down to the chassis.
Usually that's the last
part that will be together.
The reason I do this is
it's just easier to work
from the outside in.
Everything is attached to that chassis,
so you need to get off, you know,
piece by piece and just
work your way down there.
Here I'm using a rotary tool
to grind off the end of the rivet.
When rivets are put in,
they're kind of mushroomed at the end
so that they won't fall out.
So you need to take off that ridge
so that you can pull the rivet out
and allow the pieces to come off.
When I take them apart,
I use a lot of different tools.
A screwdriver and pliers
are the main tools I use.
Usually you can use the screwdriver
to bend out the tab a little bit,
and then once you get
it away from the toy,
then you can use your
pliers to fully bend it out.
And those tabs are what's going to hold
a lot of the parts together,
so it allows you to get those tabs out
and slide the truck apart.
Once the truck's completely disassembled,
I take it over to my sandblasting booth
and I try to remove
all the paint and rust.
Likely, the rust came
from, just over time,
this toy being played with,
probably left outside,
it would get beat up, it
would get paint chips.
So anytime you have exposed steel to air
and to moisture in the air and oxygen,
that's when you get rust forming.
I'm removing the rust with a sandblaster.
It's a sandblast cabinet,
and the media inside of it
is spraying out aluminum oxide.
So you can think of it like
a really abrasive powder
that gets shot through the gun.
So you get a lot of air behind it,
and it's just blowing it at
that toy as hard as it can,
and that abrasive material
will take off any rust,
paint, or anything
that's left on the metal.
You have to remove all the rust before
you repaint it or powder-coat it.
Any rust or oxide that's
left underneath that layer
will eventually continue to rust
and come through your paint
or come through your powder coat,
or it may not even stick
properly in the first place.
Well, we're down to bare metal.
Now we can go ahead and
powder-coat our parts.
For powder coating, I use
an Eastwood powder coater.
Pretty much what this machine does
is it takes powdered plastic
and it mixes with air
and sprays the powder at the parts.
And then there's an electrical charge
inside the powder-coating gun,
which is going to discharge
with the powder in the air
and pretty much electrically charge
that cloud of powder.
That electrified air wants
to find the closest ground,
and that's what causes
it to stick to the part.
So, as you watch it get powder-coated,
you'll see that the cloud of dust
just clings to the metal.
After it's coated,
I put it in my little electric oven.
It gets up to about
400 degrees Fahrenheit.
And what that's going to do
is melt down that powder.
And that's where you see it change color.
It'll go from a dull
color to a glossy color.
That's called the flow.
Once it flows out, then
you allow it to cure,
and that's what's going to
harden the color on there.
All said and done, powder
coating's very quick.
From putting it in the oven
till the time you can
take it out and handle it,
it's about 15, 20 minutes.
So now I'm going to go ahead
and just clean the tires.
I'm only washing the black
rubber part of the tire,
because I'm just going to clean these up
and use them as is.
I just put this in a
solution of Simple Green
inside my ultrasonic cleaner,
and I'm running it at
about 40 degrees Celsius
for about 20 minutes,
just vibrating the parts.
And all that's going to do
is just remove any of the dirt
and crud that's caught in the crevices
and the tread on the tires.
So now the white-walled side
of the tire is all stained,
so I need to get this
back to the white color.
I put this in a mix of
hydrogen peroxide and bleach,
and then you want to
expose it to UV light.
So I usually just put it outside
in the sun for a few days,
and that bleaches it back
to the original white color.
This truck is a little rare
because of the moving body on the back.
That makes it a little uncommon.
I know a lot of people out there
seek these kind of operational vehicles,
the ones that have a lot
of moving parts on them.
So the most difficult
part of the restoration
is definitely going to be
putting this thing back together.
There are a lot of rivets
located underneath the body
that need to all be in place
so that the body will
move up and down properly
and everything will function as it should.
Once I have everything
cleaned up and painted,
I'll usually start by assembling the cab.
I usually do this because
it's got the windshield,
and it's just a nice, easy part
that I can just start to assemble
before I start moving on to the chassis.
So, when I'm putting it back together,
I try to use the original style rivets.
And then I use a special tool
that'll crimp them in the same style
that this would've had from the factory.
The two main tools I use for reassembling
is a clamp tool called the Pintonka tool,
and that just crushes the
original style rivets.
It's specially designed just for Tonkas
and pinball machines.
And the other tool is
a small brass hammer.
One side of the head's brass,
the other side's nylon,
and that allows me to bend the tabs
without marring any of the paintwork.
The logos are reproduction
stickers I find online.
There's a bunch of reproduction companies
out there that make them,
and I just get them from
there and reapply them.
And after all that, it's fully assembled
and ready to be played with again.